michel beaucage marchand bonjour merci
d'être ici avec nous sur la scène de
l'espace jean racine à s'arrimer de
chevreuse
nous sommes là à l'occasion du 17e
festival jazz à toute heure voilà donc
vous êtes l'initiateur et donc on va
faire mieux connaissance avec vous déjà
alors qui êtes vous donc dans la vie
civile dans la vie civile je suis
quelqu'un qui dirige un collège à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines depuis cinq
ans et qui pendant très longtemps avant
a été directeur d'école à chevreuse
bonjour j'ai un parcours assez long et
complet dans l'éducation nationale ce
qui m'a amené au contact d'avoir des
petits enfants et maintenant les
adolescents à exercer un métier qui m'a
toujours beaucoup plu et qui m'a enrichi
et qui m'a aussi fait comprendre
l'importance de la culture pour les
enfants les jeunes et j'ai toujours été
très attaché à sa d'accord alors
concrètement comment vous est venue
cette idée de créer ce festival jazz à
toute heure alors on est parent c'est
une idée de copains comme on vend ce
genre de projet les copains en question
c'était les parents d'élèves de l'école
avec qui j'avais eu l'idée de monter un
spectacle qu'on organisait chaque année
la fête de fin d'année des élèves pour
les parents et puis pour s'amuser un
soir on s'était dit pourquoi on ferait
pas un spectacle des parents pour les
enfants
d'accord on est à chevreuse on a cherché
un ordinaire on est dans le primaire en
96 et donc on s'est bien amusé avec sas
a eu beaucoup de succès spectacles
musicaux donc c'était les parents qui
jouait pour les enfants voilà le plan
qui jouait il ya une bonne ambiance dans
cette école oui c'est un très bonne
ambiance et donc
bah ça m'a donné le goût du spectacle
c'est ça que j'écris c'est comme ça que
c'est venu oui voilà c'est rigolo ça
vous a révélé ce goût pour organiser
pour participer aussi vous êtes musicien
roumaine musiciens mais très très
modèles amateurs très amateur équipe la
saxo donc l'intérêt pour le jazz
mais c'est surtout après l' envie
d'organiser des spectacles qui est né à
l'issue de deux c'est très beau
spectacle on n'a fait que les parents
d'élèves
on avait quand même mille personnes dans
le gymnase de chevreuse pour 5000
habitants à chevreuse c'est génial on a
quand même réussi dans le plus grand
spectacle à mettre 180 personnes sur
scène
oui pas tout en même temps d'enfin tour
à tour il ya un gros potentiel de deux
musiciens et puis d'acteurs qui avait
aussi des acteurs des chanteurs
c'était assez amusant et de là je me
suis dit pourquoi ne pas essayer de
faire quelque chose avec des
professionnels pour le contrat des
musiciens professionnels et je savais
parce que je me suis toujours beaucoup
intéressé aux jazz que andré ceccarelli
habitait saint rémy les chevreuse
c'était un point de départ finalement
voilà c'est ça le vrai point de départ
en fait je suis allé voir andré alors
pour les personnes qui ne connaissent
pas mme andré ceccarelli andré
ceccarelli c'est l'un des plus grands
batteurs de jazz au monde actuellement
et c'est pas une forfanterie de le dire
c'est vraiment une réalité c'est
quelqu'un qui a un parcours exceptionnel
qui l'a amené à jouer dans la pop music
dans la variété
alors on peut citer quelques longs très
emblématique et la jouer dans la variété
française pas rompu avec michel jonasz à
claude nougaro la variété internationale
il était le batteur tina turner hall
arts exemple voilà il a fait des
tournées avec les plus grands musiciens
de jazz comme de stan getz dexter gordon
sont des légendes du jazz vont et il a
été pendant plus de quinze ans le
batteur de 18 joueurs
et la liste est interminable c'est
quelqu'un qui a extrêmement reconnu par
les musiciens parce qu'il a un jeu très
particulier très aérien très
reconnaissable
que qui a inspiré normes aimant tous les
musiciens c'est quelqu'un qui a aussi
toujours eu la volonté d'accueillir
beaucoup de jeunes musiciens de les
promouvoir sa sécurité en sang mais
transmet son art et sa il envie de
partager sa musique âge et ça c'est très
important pour lui et donc quand je suis
allé le voir
je connaissais pas du tout à l'époque
fin je le connaissais comme artiste bon
je lui ai expliqué notre projet qui
était un projet de copains comme j'ai
dis donc un projet de festival vous ai
dit on va on va essayer de faire ça tous
les ans avec des professionnels voilà
alors oui à chevreuse alors un saint
rémy les chevreuse et rémy voit là
puisque ici ou nous sommes dans l'espace
jean racine c'est la seule salle de
spectacle qu'il y avait à l'époque dans
les environs et donc je suis noir le
maire de chevreuse à l'époque et je lui
ai dit est ce qu'on pourrait monter un
projet commun avec la mairie de saint
rémy les chevreuse c'était déjà un
embryon d'intercommunalité c'est
important pour le festival d'aujourd'hui
est donc grâce aux deux maires celui de
chevreuse celui c1 mais les cheveux on a
monté le premier festival jazz à toute
heure en 1999 qui ne durait qu'une
journée dans lequel il y avait que
quatre concerts deux concerts avec des
musiciens professionnels de concert les
musiciens amateurs
d'accord c'était une émission de la
région vous ouvriez les musiciens
amateurs c'était des musiciens de la
région il est musicien professionnel
c'est l'émission qui sont devenus très
célèbre par la suite notamment stefano
di battista que nous avons programmé
encore cette année qui a joué la semaine
dernière et edouard ferlet keita stefano
baptiste est un saxophoniste italien qui
est devenue maintenant vraiment
quelqu'un d'important sur la scène jazz
internationale
et puis edouard ferlet qui est un
pianiste français qui est beaucoup fait
les musiques de films enfin si quelqu'un
qui dans le milieu jazz est devenu
important car nommé donc on avait un
petit peu eu de la chance et le nez à
l'époque ça vous a donné l'élan et le
l'entousiasme pour continuer finalement
le petit à petit ce festival a grandi au
niveau des dates de concerts puisque
aujourd'hui on est à combien de date
pour cette année pendant quatre ans bac
ouais
le festival se déroule pendant cinq
week-ends tous les vendredi samedi
dimanche
dakar est sûre selon les années entre 10
et 12 communes différentes
on est en tournée comme les artistes
dans le département deux jours le sud
des îles dans la vallée
voilà dans le parc naturel régional et
les villes portes du parc
ok et est ce que c'est je vois là la
fiche de cette année avec des est-ce que
justement ça que je voulais dire en
premier
jazz à toute heure mais pas que voilà
ces nouveaux se met pas que et des deux
camps de cette année alors qu'est ce qui
veut dire alors il veut dire que lorsque
nous avons créé le festival on était
vraiment un festival de jazz t.jaz.un
grâce andré ceccarelli on a pu
accueillir vraiment des grosses
pointures du jazz international parce
que le crédit de son nom a fait que les
musiciens accepté de venir je fais
confiance
ici nous ont fait confiance c'était
important et puis depuis 4 5 ans
l'engouement pour le jazz a un petit peu
baissé et alors qu'on avait les taux de
fréquentation exceptionnelle puis a eu
l'effet de la crise également on s'est
dit qu'il fallait amorcer un virage sur
la programmation
peut-être que mes goûts aussi
on se sont diversifiées moi j'ai
toujours une boîte izia fille
en tout cas on a commencé à introduire
d'autres musique le jazz le blues bon
quelle musique très parente du jazz mais
ses proches à ses proches
les musiques du monde on retrouve aussi
beaucoup dans le jazz
et puis deux le voilà d'année en année
on a franchi le pas donc maintenant il
ya du rock la chanson française il ya de
l'électro il ya vraiment à peu près
toutes les musiques qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui pas toutes les musiques mais
beaucoup de genres différents décrets
représentatif de digues ou un peu voilà
du public eric d'accord et est ce que
vous alliez j'allais dire que en fait on
est très attentif on est une équipe et
vous êtes maintenant
alors cette année on est sans arjen et
vol c'est une équipe entièrement
constitué de bénévoles et on a un comité
d'organisation d'une douzaine de
personnes qui gèrent l'ensemble des
événements du festival
l'objet de l'association c'est la
création du lien social à partir de
l'organisation d'un événement culturel
et c'est très important pour nous ce
lien social parce que c'est ce qui
motive véritablement les 106 bénévoles
qui accepte d'organiser ce festival
c'est la rencontre se sont pas tous des
amateurs de musique est assez talent pur
un mot du dja et non non c'est vraiment
la volonté d'organiser un événement
culturel ce qui a fait la renommée du
festival
c'est à la fois la programmation
spéciale pour l'arrêter c'est la qualité
de l'accueil
en plus on avance à d'accord et alors
donc vous dites différents types de
cancer qu'est ce que ça veut dire
différents types de concert nous avons
des vraies salles de spectacle comme
l'espace jean racine sur yvette donc des
salons gradins comme la salle des
récollets façon classique qui nous
permettent de programmer des artistes à
plus forte renommée pour des questions
budgétaires parce que on a une jauge de
450 places et pardon alors comme on les
paye ses artistes
alors où il devra tout de suite on est
soyons amoureux c'est pas
on a failli officiellement le chien
facture mais ça doit être est ce que là
cette année on attend 2 novembre
arthur ashe sur raul paz et liane foly
police michael jones michael jones voilà
ce ne sont pas des perdreaux gratuit
c'est pas les restos du coeur alors on
les paye l'association à un triple
financement un financement institutions
publiques est très important et sur
lesquels on est très militant comme
toutes les organisations de ce type
parce que sans les subventions publiques
tout ça serait impossible
les subventions publiques sont
essentiellement les communes et le
conseil général des yvelines et une
toute petite partie le parc naturel
régional
ensuite nous avons des mécènes qui vous
suivent qui nous suivent
on peut laisser passion peut les nommer
enfin bon donc ça c'est vraiment très
important parce que le mécénat culturel
et l'alliance du financement public et
privé c'est vraiment dans l'air du temps
rien de la gamme c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel
et puis la billetterie bien sûr la bei
christian alors on a un prix moyen de
billets de 20 26 euros pour le premier
billet et avec un système qu'on appelle
le billet combo le deuxième billet pour
un autre concert est à 10 euros mais
parce qu en fait l'idée c'est d'aller à
plusieurs concerts festivals et voilà en
général on ne va pas qu'un seul concert
non à cette formule ce qui fait qu'on a
un prix à 18 heures au préservatif
d'accord juste donc ça c'est de les les
concerne donc classique entre guillemets
je vous avez coupé la parole donc on y
revient après il ya d'autres sortes de
concerts donc dans des lieux moins
attendu si je puis dire comme par
exemple alors les salles polyvalentes
des petits villages accueillent voir des
gymnases dans certains cas voir des
lieux
eux qui ne sont pas au départ destinée
concert par exemple je pense à la maison
aragon et elsa triolet
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ou là on amène
un aménagement complet cirque on amène
le son la lumière mais on amène aussi
une formule club avec des petites tables
où les gens peuvent se restaurer boire à
se restaurer c'est vrai ça montrait les
gers et grignoter août
non c'est plutôt des plans de chan
choses comme ça à boire un coup votre
offre extrêmement variés et finalement
toujours y trouver son compte
et juste pour terminer je pense que vous
y tenez aussi le lien que vous avez
gardé
enfin qui est permanent avec les enfants
votre côté enseignants et proches des
enfants des élèves comment s'est
concrètement comment vous tenez
concrètement alors concrètement on
invite tous les élèves des écoles
primaires des villes participantes arrêt
à des concerts qui sont spécialement
fait pour eux alors ils sont
spécialement fait pour eux parce qu'ils
sont adaptés dans la durée sont
déconseillés lourde car aucun but pour
être dans leur capacité d'attention mais
avec des artistes qui sont à la grande
programmation sont pas des concerts pour
enfants arabes et non c'est bon le
rennais lille pourtant ni voilà l'idée
est de mettre des enfants face aux
artistes de la même manière qu'on les
met face aux offres quand on les envoie
visiter un musée donc un travail de
préparation des enseignants pour les
élections voir qu'ils ont écouté ils
sont très attentifs
malgré le fait qu'il soit dans une salle
noire de 500 personnes c'est pas évident
de garder 500 entre 6 et 11 ans ces
conditions-là mais en plus ils ont pris
l'habitude puisque depuis les concerts
sera fait une 12 ans qu'on les fait donc
les élèves viennent chaque année des
collégiens alors on a eu quelques
expériences mais une très belle
expérience notamment avec le collège de
bonnel
il y avait dix vies qui était très
impliqué où on avait monté un spectacle
avec les ados du collège de bonnel pour
les enfants du primaire et ça aussi
c'est très porteur d'un quart en plus
c'est encore en plus parce que c'était
intéressant de montrer aux primaires
voyez vous quand vous serez au collège
voilà ce qu'ils font reka ça aussi vos
amis collégiens génial ben écoutez bravo
c'est une belle histoire de transmission
et de partage
donc je vous j'encourage tout le monde à
aller voir le programme est encore riche
et varié de cette année et puis longue
vie minimale merci mais c'est le bocage
marchand